we're here with Rebel Wilson and you've
been in some iconic films so we wanted
to break them down in our favorite game
called will you play it with us yes this
is behind the scenes okay
okay
anything that comes to mind a dirty
little secret a weird tidbit a moment a
fly on the wall a memory a fun fact
bridesmaids Bridesmaids
my first movie here in America
um so right before we we shot Kristen
Wiig takes us out to a strip club so
it's like me Maya Rudolph Melissa
McCarthy and we go to this strip club
called Hollywood men and it was like
crazy and then she buys me the tank top
it makes me wear it throughout the night
it was really too tight for me and so
I'm there like with the Hollywood man
and we're all getting lap dances and
everything it was wild wild and crazy
okay this is that's exactly
you know that's what I'm looking for now
I can live there red free in my mind
yeah all right
foreign
something that probably nobody knows
apart from the people that were
physically there
I had a solo in our regional
performances it was called Turn the Beat
Around yeah pretty cool song uh but I
was sick as a dog I had bronchitis so
they come into the trailer and they
inject me twice with steroids yup so
yeah that I could get out there and do
it and every time I watch that scene I'm
going turn the bed and I'm like I'm like
a crazy person because I am like on some
kind of steroids
boom okay
oh my girls and I love these movies so
much
um okay so my co-star in this movie was
a monkey one of the very famous animal
actors called Crystal she's also in The
Hangover movies so Crystal
um I was really excited to wear it was
very famous monkey and I said would I be
able to have a photo with Crystal like a
selfie
um and her trainer said not now she's
mentally preparing for a scene
and then I peek into her turn I was very
and I think she literally was like like
she was a method actor preparing for the
scene going wow yeah I mean incredible
well don't mess with Crystal heard Meryl
Streep are preparing all right I love
this movie so much how to be single
I love this movie shot here in New York
City
the biggest thing I remember about this
movie
is this is the first time I ever got a
UTI aha whilst filming this movie did
you take the cranberry juice well yeah I
was going anyone have any cranberry
juice just like a dead giveaway yeah it
was obvious what had happened to me and
yeah I didn't know what to do and I had
to get medical attention
anyway
[Applause]
stuff that nobody knows listen every
woman in this audience here understands
and I'm sure there's a male
all right last but not least
such a meaningful film an academy
award-winning film JoJo rabbit yeah
yeah
so I had to shoot a machine gun in the
movie and they take you out to just this
field to practice I guess so they're
like well obviously you won't shoot
anything on set it will come to set and
you'll just pretend to shoot and a
machine guns are really heavy so there
and then I'm trying to shoot it and
they're like okay you've got to recoil
and stuff so I'm just going
for like an hour pretending to shoot
this machine gun
and I may be bringing some wind maybe
that'll look better like a wind machine
so they blow the wind machine in my face
and I'm going
oh my God like I I but it actually
looked quite good in the film uh
committed it looked real uh but it was
hard it was hard to pretend to shoot
well yeah you everything you do from
your engagement to all of these
incredible films to your health and
wellness to like setting other people up
for success in love in their life what
can't you do well I want everybody to
because there's so many singles out
there and you're you're single I'm a
single I mean it's perfect she said I
want everyone to find love because I
know
I know you know and it's your birthday
today
I got a little surprise for you for your
birthday yeah is that okay actually
oh thank you
thank you
perfect thank you guys so much all right
it's two things one I heard you were an
Old El Paso fan yes
and these are your favorite snacks from
Australia that you can't obviously
procure here at the market so we just
wanted them to have oh
[Applause]
yes
and these Caramelo koalas when I first
came to America and I only had one
suitcase when I first came to America a
quarter of the suitcase was filled with
a big box of it so these actually like
really sentimental to me and they're
amazing oh you have to try one you are
sentimental to all of us happy birthday
happy engagement Happy Everything
it loves you so much thank you so much
thank you for coming back
thank you
[Music]